[Applaudissements]
il est rare de voir un parti politique
dévoilé son programme ou si tous avant
une élection mais john singleton
débattre tout l'été oui crowley et need
you pour pippa et on nous dit encore
pipeau ce nouveau pack du npd propose
une réforme majeure du système de santé
de façon à couvrir les examens de la vue
les soins dentaires et même l'aide à
santé mentale il promet aussi un
programme universel d'assurance
médicaments qu'il implanterait dès l'an
prochain
les gens ont dit la même chose contamine
tommy de lagos a proposé un système de
santé pour tous les canadiens
ils ont dit la même chose que c'est pas
possible donc maintenant il y à des
critiques qui vont dire la même chose
encore mais on est fiers de notre plan
on est confiant qu'il les gens ont
besoin de notre plan parce que les gens
ont besoin d aide pour financer cette
réforme qui coûterait d'univers il
indique qu'il hausserait les impôts sur
les entreprises et pour les canadiens
les plus riches
on est dans une société où les
inégalités sont croissantes les riches
toujours plus riches alors il ya des
marges de manoeuvre on peut aller
chercher de l'argent
augmenter les impôts de ceux qui gagnent
plus de 210 m $ par année
avoir une taxe sur les fortunes de plus
de 20 millions de dollars côté
environnemental une [ __ ] propose
d'éliminer le plastique à usage unique
d'ici 2021 de faire du canada un état
carboneutre d'ici 2030
j'ai l'impression que le npd ça passe
pour sortir quelque chose pour accrocher
sur le plan social alors que ça va
vraiment très mal même avec des mesures
populaires 2006 pourrait avoir de la
difficulté à s'imposer au québec qu'il
est d'adopter sa loi sur les i je pense
que les gens vont passer au dessus des
symboles que des signes puisse dire
carrément qu'est-ce que sur la table qui
répond à mes besoins puis qui je veux
voir au parlement pour se battre pour
moi à l'échelle nationale le npd
récolterait 13% des intentions de vote
mais au québec selon un récent sondage
serait temps sec 1 place derrière le
bloc québécois et même le parti vert si
michel marsolais radio canada montréal